deutschlands wirtschaft wächst wieder
gute zahlen im dritten quartal aber wie
es weitergeht ist ungewiss
immer mehr corona tests bei rasant
steigenden infektionszahlen ist ein teil
der labore inzwischen am limit und
starkes erdbeben in der ägäis an der
türkischen küste stürzten häuser ein
mehrere menschen sterben mehr als 400
werden verletzt
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und am finalen dass es
ihr nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
freitag sport nachher in der sendung mit
kristin otto und später guten abend wir
beginnen mit der lage der deutschen
wirtschaft mitten in der pandemie da
gibt es heute einerseits zahlen die
hoffnung machen im dritten quartal
dieses jahres ist es wieder kräftig
aufwärts gegangen mit der wirtschaft
über den gesamten jahr 2020 steht
allerdings weiter ein - und dann kommen
jetzt ja wieder neue strenge
einschränkungen gucken wir uns die
zahlen mal kurz an
privater konsum und gestiegene exporte
sorgten für ein wachstum von 8,2 prozent
im dritten quartal gegenüber dem zweiten
für das gesamte jahr rechnet die
regierung damit dass das
bruttoinlandsprodukt um 5,5 prozent
zurückgeht peter böhme hat mehr welche
leiste das denn sein die deutschen haben
es sich im home office zeiten daheim
schön gemacht renovieren den garten
herrichten oder gleich selbst was bauen
ich habe mir gedanken wohnung
verschönern kann und habe darunter
anderem sideboard gebaut
ein regal man kam plötzlich auch neue
ideen liegen gebliebene sachen konnten
erledigt werden
im garten konnte man einiges machen
bau und gartenmärkte haben unter corona
stark zugelegt ebenso wie teile des
einzelhandels oder der online handel
inklusive post krisengewinner heute
verkündete der bundeswirtschaftsminister
eine kleinere wirtschaft schneller als
erwartet zwar immer noch ein minus beim
bruttoinlandsprodukt für dieses jahr von
5,5 prozent allerdings war im frühjahr
noch mit 6,3 prozent minus gerechnet
worden
vor allem das dritte quartal bescherte
ordentlich wachstum das sehr gute dritte
quartal zeigt damit dass die deutsche
wirtschaft sich vor der pandemie in
einer starken verfassung befunden hat
und es zeigt dass die deutsche
wirtschaft im stande ist auch unter den
bedingungen einer solchen pandemie
wachstumskräfte zu entwickeln wachsen
das würde auch steffen stück aus leipzig
gern mit seinem start-up zwölf
mitarbeiter ihre idee der digitale
nachlass eine online-plattform in der
man alle dokumente verträge atteste
immer griffbereit speichern kann
dafür braucht startkapital eine halbe
million euro fehlen noch
unsere größte problem ist dass wir
unsere komplette in die entwicklung
unserer plattform vorfinanzieren müssen
und dafür versuchen halt investoren und
wir merken halt sehr stark seit märz
diesen jahres dass die investoren das
kapital zurückhaltend weil halt unklar
ist wie sich die lage durch bewohner
weiterentwickelt unklar
das bleibt etwa auch im flugverkehr im
tourismus bei hotels in der gastronomie
für nächstes jahr rechnet altmaier mit
4,4 prozent wachstum
doch die pandemie könnte ihm einen
strich durch die rechnung machen
ja viele sorgen also und massive
hilfsprogramme des staates es gibt in
der pandemie aber auch absolute gewinner
deutlich mehr geld haben facebook und
google eingenommen
amazon hat im letzten quartal dreimal
soviel gewinn gemacht wie im gleichen
quartal 2009/10 frank bethmann für uns
an der börse in frankfurt was heißt das
für die weltwirtschaft und auch für
gerechtigkeitsdebatte
ja die schere zwischen groß und klein
zwischen existenzkampf und mega reicht
die geht immer weiter auseinander
und die hoffnung dass die märkte diese
entwicklung selbst regulieren ist längst
dahin
die vier technologiekonzerne amazon
google facebook und apple gehören nicht
nur zu den wertvollsten unternehmen der
welt sie werden auch von quartal zu
quartal immer noch
reicher und immer noch mächtiger steuern
bezahlt haben sie in all den jahren im
übrigen lächerlich wenig auch weil
länder wie irland oder luxemburg mit
mini steuersätzen lockten und dies
ermöglichten
an anderer stelle war sich europa zwar
einiger übersät zb google mit
milliardenstrafen doch geändert hat sich
nichts in den usa denken sie nun über
schärfere geschütze nach kein privater
konzern dürfen stärker als die
demokratie sein sagen die amerikaner
dürften nicht gleich die zerschlagung
von amazon und co drohen doch man
erinnere sich an microsoft schon einmal
wurde ein übermächtiger tech konzern
durch klagen vor us gerichten in die
knie gezwungen interessante analyse
frank herzlichen dank nach frankfurt die
korona zahlen gehen weiter nach oben den
dritten tag in folge gibt es einen neuen
höchstwert bei den neuinfektionen 18
1681 corona fälle wurden innerhalb von
24 stunden von den gesundheitsämtern
registriert und auch der sieben tage
schnitt geht weiter hoch pro tag haben
sich durchschnittlich 13.500 menschen
neu mit dem virus angesteckt gestern lag
der wert noch bei 12 1720 aus
schleswig-holstein müssen alle touristen
bis spätestens 2 november abgereist sein
das hat die landesregierung in kiel
beschlossen sie verweist auf die
bundesweiten regeln für den november für
alle urlauber die derzeit auf den
nordseeinseln sind gilt die frist drei
tage länger eine ähnliche verordnung in
brandenburg dort müssen alle touristen
die sich in hotels aufhalten bis
kommenden mittwoch abreisen
es gibt mehr infektionen es gibt auch
mehr tests in der vergangenen woche
wurden in deutschland 1,2 millionen
menschen auf das corona virus getestet
die labore stehen an der
kapazitätsgrenze
sie fordern dass sich nur testen lässt
wer symptome hatte kontakt zu
infizierten oder aus risikogebieten
einreist anna duda sie arbeiten hier
sieben tage in der woche in zwei
schichten 18 stunden lang auch heute
werden die mitarbeiter innen bei bio
sense jahr rund 12.000 pcr tests
durchführen
das labor in ingelheim ist am limit
heute sind wir bei 100 prozent also und
wir nutzen wir nutzen jedes gerät wir
nutzen jeden mitarbeiter wir nutzen
jeden jeden quadratzentimeter raum hier
im haus und wie gesagt jeden tag in der
woche 100 prozent mehr geht nicht
bundesweit kämpfen die labore mit immer
mehr abstrichen die gründe
hunderttausende reiserückkehrer auch aus
nicht- risikogebieten ließen sich testen
deshalb stieg die anzahl durchgeführter
pcr tests im spätsommer an
jetzt steigen die infektionszahlen
momentan müssen die labore wöchentlich
mehr als 1,2 millionen proben abarbeiten
der anteil der positiven tests liegt
mittlerweile bei 5,7 prozent die labore
warnen mitarbeiter und material werden
knapp zeitnahe testergebnisse sind bald
nicht machbar
die gefahr ist immer dass bei einer
krassen überlastung diese zeiten länger
werden und wir dann natürlich positive
patienten zu spät entdecken das ist ein
risiko jetzt müsse man priorisieren und
in einigen bereichen auf die schnelleren
antigen tests umschwenken
sie können in bestimmten situationen
tatsächlich helfen und eingesetzt werden
stichwort zum beispiel altenpflegeheime
wo man dann doch die bewohner vielleicht
mal durch testen kann mit den fall
aufgetreten ist das muss nicht dann
unbedingt notwendiger weise für im labor
passieren ob personal oder material
jetzt gelte es die ressourcen gezielt
einzusetzen
auch andere länder stemmen sich mit
immer neuen einschränkungen gegen die
steigenden infektionszahlen belgien
verkündet in diesen minuten strengere
regeln so werden ab sonntag alle nicht
lebenswichtigen geschäfte geschlossen
und frankreich ist seit heute zum
zweiten mal landesweit im corona
lockdown wenn das haus verlassen will
braucht einen triftigen grund anselm
stern fasst zusammen der sturm vor der
ruhe
paris in der nacht hunderte kilometer
lang
einige hier sind wohl auch auf der
flucht vor den harten anti virus
maßnahmen seit heute gilt die neue
strikte ausgangssperre in der hauptstadt
und in vielen anderen französischen
metropolen raus darf nur wer einen grund
hat die arbeit etwa oder der besuch beim
arzt jeder braucht einen passierschein
der lock down ist so schwierig wenn du
alleine bist und 70 jahre alt niemanden
mehr triffst und alleine bist in deinen
vier wänden schwierig manche sagen
gefährlich die lage hier in belgien der
grund volle krankenhäusern immer mehr
kobe patienten im land kommen in die
kliniken das krisenzentrum rechnet bis
ende nächster woche mit 2000 corona
intensivpatienten das gilt als limit
krisenmodus das virus immer stärker auf
dem vormarsch
liegt es an den maßnahmen die getroffen
wurden oder liegt es am verhalten der
bevölkerung
das wird dann mix wahrscheinlich aus
beiden sein fest steht die zahlen
steigen schnell in europa und weltweit
am schlimmsten getroffen nach wie vor
die usa heute traurige rekordzahlen
schon wieder das land meldet mehr als
88.000 neue infektionen an einem tag und
das vier tage vor der wahl
mitten in der virus krise wählt amerika
am dienstag einen neuen präsidenten
immer mehr länder europas werden zucker
ohne risikogebieten aktuell auch fast
ganz österreich und italien
eine ausführliche liste der
risikogebiete in europa gibt es in der
zdf- heute frankreich hat nicht nur mit
ständig steigenden corona zahlen zu
kämpfen nach dem tödlichen messerangriff
von nizza gilt zudem die höchste
terrorwarnstufe im land heute nahmen die
polizei einen 47 jährigen fest er soll
kontakt zu dem mutmaßlichen angreifer
gehabt haben
der hatte gestern in nizza in einer
kirche drei menschen mit einem messer
getötet mindestens ein opfer wurde fast
enthauptet als tatmotiv vermuten die
ermittler islamistischen terrorismus
da der verdächtige aus tunesien stammt
ermitteln nun auch die behörden dort
unser nächstes thema in der östlichen
ägäis gab es heute mittag ein schweres
erdbeben nach angaben des türkischen
katastrophenschutzes mit einer stärke
von 6,6
das epizentrum rund 16 kilometer
nördlich der griechischen insel samos
dort starben mindestens zwei menschen es
gab kleinere tsunamis
besonders betroffen ist die großstadt
izmir in der türkei
zwölf menschen kamen hier ums leben mehr
als 400 wurden verletzt jörg brase jetzt
mit einzuleiten
ein erdbeben schreit er und stürzt von
seinem computer nach draußen 30 sekunden
lang zittert die erde eine halbe
ewigkeit
menschen geraten in panik häuserwände
reisen werden instabil stürzen ein
ich habe gefühlt wie der boden zitterte
berichtet dieser augenzeuge
du denkst nicht nach sondern willst
einfach nur noch raus
sofort sind helfer zur stelle versuchen
verschüttete zu bergen
in der provinz izmir fielen mehrere
gebäude wie kartenhäuser zusammen
angeblich nur vier davon in der
millionenmetropole selbst der
provinz-gouverneur besichtigt am
nachmittag die schäden sagt man habe
bisher 70 menschen aus den einsturz
häusern geborgen es habe viele verletzte
gegeben
der verkehr in izmir es zum stillstand
gekommen
statt uns auf unsere eigentlichen
rettungsarbeiten konzentrieren zu können
müssen wir uns auch noch darum kümmern
ich fordere daher alle aufsicht zu einem
offenen platz wie zb einem park zu
bewegen und dort zu warten
die griechische insel samos liegt nahe
des epizentrums zerstörungen auch hier
eine flutwelle rollt durch den hafen
zwei jugendliche kommen ums leben als in
einer engen gasse häuserwände einstürzen
auch in der nacht gehen die
bergungsarbeiten wie hier in izmir
weiter viele menschen könnten noch unter
den trümmern liegen die zahl der opfer
wird vermutlich noch steigen
wir sollten heute auch auf den krieg im
kaukasus schauen nach berg karabach eine
waffenruhe sollte den weg frei machen
für neue friedensgespräche zwischen
aserbaidschan und armenien
aber die waffen ruhen nicht stattdessen
neue angriffe seit jahrzehnten streiten
sich die beiden länder um die region
berg karabach im kaukasus
völkerrechtlich gehört sie zu
aserbaidschan
doch in der selbsternannten republik
leben mehrheitlich arminia tote und
verletzte gibt es längst auf beiden
seiten und es trifft auch die
schwächsten
armin coerper von dort berichtet allen
waffen stillständen zum trotz wird
weiter geschossen in der vergangenen
nacht auch zivilisten werden zu opfern
auf beiden seiten
im krankenhaus von step anna kehrt
forderten luftangriff keine toten die
patienten waren schon im untergeschoss
in der fünften woche hat man sich
eingerichtet auf dem krieg getroffen
wurde unsere entbindungsstation was
bitte kann es friedlicheres geben
der panda kehrt eine stadt die zunehmend
unter beschuss steht
was die lager für uns hier so
unübersichtlich macht ist dass es gar
keine klare frontlinie zu geben scheint
die angriffe erfolgen aus der luft und
erscheint ziemlich wahllos
beide seiten bezichtigen sich
gegenseitig verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit begangen zu haben da wir
informationen aber hier nur von
armenischer seite erhalten können wir
das nicht auf seine authentizität hin
überprüfen
hier brennt nur noch eine kerze marietta
und die anderen frauen harren seit tagen
im keller aus sie sind armenierinnen
doch irland gehört völkerrechtlich zu
aserbaidschan ein konflikt seit
jahrzehnten aserbaidschan wird von
großen ländern wie der türkei
unterstützt wir sind doch nur ein
kleines korn im wind helft uns frieden
zu finden
wir können nicht mehr mit denen zusammen
leben ich glaube an nichts mehr nur noch
an gott und an russland russland so
haben wir gesehen hat schon an der
grenze zu berg karabach posten bezogen
während aserbaidschan immer mehr land
gewinnt und dieser krieg zu einem
zwischen militärischen großmächten
anzustellen droht unser nächstes thema
vor gut einer woche polen seien
abtreibungsrecht verschärft das
verfassungsgericht hatte entschieden
dass frauen auch dann nicht abtreiben
dürfen wenn ihr kind schwere
fehlbildungen hat das urteil spaltet das
land und die proteste dagegen reißen
nicht ab seit zwei stunden läuft in
warschau
die bislang wohl größte demonstration
natalie steger berichtet aus dem ganzen
land sind sie an
zigtausende in warschau demonstrieren
gegen ein fast vollständiges
abtreibungsverbot in polen schon den
neunten tag in folge machen sie ihrer
empörung luft die stimmung wieder
friedlich wir wollen eine freie wahl
jeder mensch wir wollen verändern
deshalb bin ich hier und werde immer
wieder kommen
ihre wut richtet sich gegen das
abtreibungsgesetz politischen
verfassungsgerichts das auf
nationalkonservativer regierungslinie
ist der protest machte zuletzt auch vor
kirchen nicht halt polens konservative
kirche ist eng vernetzt mit der
regierung ich rufe alle peace mitglieder
auf und alle unsere unterstützer die
kirche zu verteidigen tatsächlich haben
bereits rechtsextreme gruppen sogenannte
national wachen vor kirchen gebetet
wollte tut die regierung alles um
aggressionen zu schüren
heute sollte der platz eines jeden
vernünftigen politikers beim protest
polens staatspräsident regierungstreu
will nun einen gesetzentwurf einbringen
der abtreibung ermöglichen soll aber nur
bei fehlbildungen die unweigerlich zum
tode führen
es ist ein später und halbherziger
versuch die lage zu beruhigen
polens staatsspitze hat offenbar
unterschätzt dass sich die frauen auch
im pandemie zeiten derart mobilisieren
es geht um mehr als abtreibung vor allem
viele junge stehen auch gegen
erzkonservative werte ihnen mindestens
sechs tote hunderttausende ohne strom an
der südostküste der usa haben unwetter
nach einem hurrikan große schäden
verursacht wirbelsturms ida weil
lousiana an land getroffen mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 175
kilometern pro stunde
dann schwächte er sich etwas ab blieb
aber stark genug um bäume zu entwurzeln
und häuser zu beschädigen
helfer suchen weiter nach vermissten
so jetzt in dieser sendung sind wir sehr
gespannt was du hast nun an bord fußball
europa league leverkusen hat verloren
und hoffenheim verbucht den zweiten sieg
im zweiten spiel vier zu eins im
belgischen gent für das team von
sebastian höhn ist der erste europäische
auswärtserfolg überhaupt und so hoch wie
nie zuvor
zurück der einzug in die zwischenrunde
ganz nah manchmal kann es auch ein
torwart sein der den grundstein für ein
offensivspektakel legt oliver baumann
früh im spiel gehalten dass strafstoß
ist der weckruf für die tsg
der von balfour deal verwandelte
handelfmeter der erste lohn für eine
dominante vorstellung es war wieder sehr
erwachsen haben nicht viel zugelassen
also ich bin ich bin sehr stolz auf die
jungs und auf den staatlichen getan
das 210 von grillitsch nach der pause
nach einem perfekten angriff und das
drei zu null durch
kino vi entscheidenden partie in der
nachspielzeit darf der ehemalige
heidenheimer team kleindienst noch den
belgischen ehrentreffer erzielen bevor
dafür den hoffenheimer schlusspunkt
setzt unter einen beeindruckenden
europäischen auswärtsauftritt höhepunkt
des sechsten spieltages der fußball
bundesliga das top spiel morgen abend
borussia mönchengladbach gegen
spitzenreiter rb leipzig beide
mannschaften nach dem frust und der
enttäuschung in der königsklasse unter
erfolgsdruck
julian nagelsmann und marco rose zwei
trainer die momentan eine sache
verbindet sie sind im gespräch bei
borussia dortmund als nachfolger von
lucien favre
es ist geschrieben und der russischen
muss damit umgehen und ich muss damit
umgehen
es ist im moment für mich einfach kein
thema weil morgen abend geht es erstmal
für roses borussia gegen den
tabellenführer und die leipziger haben
sich einiges vorgenommen
wir können jetzt den besten saisonstart
der klubgeschichte machen
mit 16 von 18 punkten um damit die
tabellenführung zu verteidigen und die
nächste stufe zu nehmen
es ist nun mal so dass der erfolg eine
treppe ist und leider keine tür und wir
sind jetzt ein paar mal durch eine tür
gegangen aber wir müssen immer wieder
verändert dass wir auch die treppe
laufen müssen ohne dabei zu stolpern
über marco rose und borussia
mönchengladbach
und alles zum topspiel morgen haben dem
aktuellen sportstudio bereits 20 nach 10
so kassieren jetzt zur vorsicht denn was
jetzt kommt ist mitreißend wahnsinns
wellen am strand von mazar in portugal
selbst für die allerbesten server eine
herausforderung die big waves von lazard
die gewaltigsten wellen der welt
entstehen wegen eines besonderen
naturphänomens wenige kilometer vor der
küste verläuft 1 2 230 kilometer langer
unter wassergraben der für diese bilder
sorgt kann man kaum hinschauen das
wetter sieht ganz gut aus ein sonniger
samstag wird das für viele werden nur im
nordosten halten sich mehr wollten
gunther tiersch hat gleich alle details
für sie danke für ihr großes interesse
von uns allen nicht empfehle ihnen das
heute journal um 518 mit der kollegin
marietta slomka und morgen freut sich
hier barbara hahlweg auf sie machen sie
sich einen sehr angenehmen freitagabend
[Musik]
meine liebe zuschauer es wird wärmer und
sonniger bei uns wir haben ein
hochdruckgebiet über den alpen und das
bringt uns eine regenpause aber schon
über westeuropa und auf dem atlantik
formieren sich neue sturmtiefs und schon
am sonntag kommt die nächste regenfront
zu uns vorher würde es kaum noch regnen
der regen zieht meist heute nacht schon
ab über den osten nur leichter regen ist
das ansonsten gibt es ein paar
nebelfelder und am kühlsten wird es an
den alpen mit rund 2 grad in
norddeutschland haben wir morgen noch
anfangs stärkere bewölkung nach osten
hin kann es vielleicht am vormittag noch
etwas tröpfeln nachmittag wird es
trocken und von südwesten lockert auch
hier mehr und mehr auf bei diesem recht
kräftigen südwind den wir haben
der winter im süden der ist nur sehr
schwach aber wir haben sehr viel
sonnenschein in süddeutschland teilweise
von einem wolkenlosen himmel wie hier an
den alpen ein wunderbarer herbsttag wird
das bei temperaturen die noch ansteigen
es wird wärmer 14 bis 17 grad und am
oberrhein knapp 20 grad am sonntag
allerdings wird schon wieder regnen in
deutschland ab montag wird stürmisch und
sehr mild und dienstag ist es wieder
deutlich kühler
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie es gut